GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
ONE TWO THREE. WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE A QUORUM SO IF ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OR WATCHING
FROM THEIR OFFICES PLEASE AHEAD
TO ROOM FOR. THIRTY SEVEN I
THINK. SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE THEY ALREADY SAID
THAT PART. DUE TO THE COVERED
PANDEMIC. WE CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WITH MODIFY COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES. FOR THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT. AT
TODAY'S HEARING SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS REQUIRED IN THE
AUDIENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM I'M GONNA PAUSE ON
THE OPENING REMARKS FOR A
SECOND TO ESTABLISH. A QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE
SAY ARE TELL YEAH C. R. TELL
HERE BENNETT. BENNETT HERE LOW.
THIS YEAR MAYES HERE MULLIN.
BLANCA RUBIO ONE RUBIO HERE
GREAT QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
MUST WEAR A MASK OVER YOUR
MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL TIMES WE
ALSO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO TESTIFY IN THE
COMMITTEE INCLUDING ALLOWING
TESTIMONY AT A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL IN ALLOWING
TESTIMONY BY PHONE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
OUR TIME LIMITS WE WILL NOT
TOLERATE CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
AND DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE TO THE ORDERLY CONDUCT
OF THE COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR OR
BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE INCLUDING
VEILED THREATS IS PROHIBITED
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. THE COMMITTEE HAS ONE
BILL ON ITS AGENDA TODAY IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
ITS BUSINESS IN THE A LOT OF
TIME WE'RE LIMITING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS THERE WILL
BE A MAXIMUM OF TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WITH A LIMIT OF TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS. AFTER WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE UP TO IT UP TO
THIRTY MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN THE ROOM.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS. THESE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL BE
RULED OUT OF ORDER AND I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS. IF
YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH
ON THE PHONE. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THE BILL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
AND WHO WISH TO CALL IN TO
REGISTER YOUR POSITION. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER
SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE FOUR AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH ALL THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE WAY WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. THE ONLY
ITEM ON THE AGENDA TODAY IS SB
THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER NUMBER
CENTER THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS YOU HAVE SEEN SB
THIRTY FIVE BEFORE THE BODY OF
THE BILL WAS DESIGNED TO.
PREVENT MISLEADING INFORMATION
OR BLOCKING ACCESS TO THE POLLS
WHAT THIS DOES IS THIS ADDS
SOME TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS- THE
DEAL WITH THE- L. ALIGNMENT OF
THE DEADLINE FOR GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES TO COMPLY WITH
EXISTING TAX RETURN DISCLOSURE
LAWS THERE WAS LITTLE. GLITCH
HERE OF LATE. THIS HELPS TO
RESOLVE ANY AMBIGUITY THAT MAY
EXIST. ALSO CREATES A
NOTIFICATION PROCESS THE CURE
PERIOD FOR CANDIDATES TO REMEDY
ANY DEFICIENCIES. ARE THERE TO
WITNESS IS THE TEST ACTUALLY
ONE WITNESS AND ONE OTHER
PERSON TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS
ERIC GARRIS DEPUTY SECTORS
STATE. LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS I
BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND MISTER
STEVE RATES VERY SMART LAWYER
IS ALSO AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GREAT THANK YOU
CENTER AMBERG. AND WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO- MISTER GARRIS. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS THAT AS
THE OFFICE STATED THAT THE
SECRETARY BLIZZARD FOR ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE
DOCUMENT WEBER IN SUPPORT OF
THE S. B. ASSEMBLY NOT THIRTY
FIVE AND IN A MATTER TO BE
GREAT BUT I JUST THINK THE FOR
THE 4% OF THE MOMENT- JUST SAY
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE DEADLINE
OF SUBMISSION FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO RECOGNIZE CANADA FORMS
NINETY DAYS PARTS ALEXION.
WRITTEN IN THE TO SB THIRTY
FIVE SIMPLY OUTLINE THE
DEADLINE FOR GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATES TO COMPLY WITH TAX
RETURN DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
WITH THE REGULAR CANDIDATE
FILING DEADLINES CLOSING- SB
THIRTY FIVE ALSO CREATES A
NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND A CURE
PERIOD PER CANISTER REMEDY ANY
DEFICIENCIES. AGAIN THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER. AND SEND
ARMOR DO YOU SAY GOT SOME
ELSE'S ANOTHER PRIMARY WITH-
WHEN ISN'T SUPPORTER FOR NOW
MISTER MISTER RACES AVAILABLE
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
GREAT SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY PRIMER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY FIVE.
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME.
THE ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE WILL
START IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHICH
IS TO PROVIDE A POSITION ON SB.
THIRTY FIVE. SEEING NONE MOVING
IT OVER TO- WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB
THIRTY FIVE. THE MAN WE WILL
NOW OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON A
SB THIRTY FIVE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTY FIVE. Q. AT CENTER THE
COMMENT QUEUE IN SUPPORT. ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
LINES IN Q. FIRST WE HAVE LINE
SIXTEEN. YOU'RE NOT GIVING THIS
BILL EQUAL REPRESENTATION YOU
NEED TO ALLOW THE PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO IT.
WOULD I WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND OR YOU'RE
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION THE
BILL PLAY. YOU ARE NOW GIVING
THANK YOU MUCH WE WANTED NEXT
CALL. NEXT CALLER LINE
SEVENTEEN. MISTER CHAIR
SENATOR- BURKE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS TONY TOOK
GUERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALIGNMENT.
NINETEEN MY NAME IS SERRA AT
THE PHILLY FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I AM TOTALLY AGAINST SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE NUMBER. EIGHTEEN I
CAN TRY AND PLASTER COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED S. B. THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
FOURTEEN YES AND I AM NICOLE
YANG THE CHAPTER CHAIR OF
POTTER COUNTY FUNDS FOR LIBERTY
AND WE ARE STRONG WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LEVINE.
TWENTY HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY FEEL THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
TWENTY FOUR. HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU- OKAY THIS IS ERICA
WALKER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU. IF
THERE ARE ANY PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I THINK MODERATE JUST
AGAIN FROM WORKING SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO ANY CALLERS AT
ALL FORTY. VERY GOOD IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOU PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
ALSO HAVE LINE TEN. APOLOGIZE
WE'VE LOST THE LINE WE HAVE TWO
MORE HOWEVER- THEY DON'T ALTER
MY NUMBERS YET NUMBER LINE
TWENTY THREE WELL OKAY THANK
YOU TWENTY THREE. YES HELLO
THIS IS LIBERTY- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU. LINE TEN UNITS OPEN.
WILL MOBILIZE TWENTY FIVE WAIT
YES LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD THANKS. YEAH HI HELLO
MY NAME'S DIANA I'M FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND WE DO NOT
KNOW WHAT NUMBER WE ARE IT'S SO
YOU KNOW WE CALL LAN SO THERE
NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED- I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU.
WHEN WE HAVE LINE TWENTY FIVE.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA
LOPEZ AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
THIRTY FIVE I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
PHONE LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTION
SECONDS. GOT A MOTION GOT A
SECOND. ANY COMMENTS NOT SEEING
ANY CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE TONIGHT VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE A CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE
ANY DEFICIENCIES IN THE TAX
RETURN DOCUMENTS THEY SUBMIT.
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS
NOTIFICATION AND CORE PROCESS
IN PLACE BEFORE THE JUNE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO. THIS IS ME
BEFORE THE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY
ELECTION. I LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SECRETARY OF
STATE FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. AND HAPPY TO
RECOMMEND SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BERMAN
HI BERMAN I SAY ARE TELL THERE
ARE TWO IS NOT VOTING BENNETT
BY BENNETT TODD LOW. WELL I MY
NAME. MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I
THAT BILL PASSES WITH SIX AYE
VOTES- AND THAT THE GERMANS ARE
MEETING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING.